good morning everybody the rain the snow
is gone but boy look at that beautiful
scenery up in our spring mountains
nearly a foot of snow up there in the
spring mountains and some really good
rain totals too we'll go over those in
just a minute it is cold out there our
neighborhoods are about 10 to sometimes
15 degrees colder this morning than we
were yesterday where we had all the
cloud cover 37 at the lakes 39 at
aliante upper 30 centennial hills
summerlin in the mid 30s it's freezing
at red rock and teens up there at kyle
canyon with some nice snow 36 in sunrise
mountain 35 in henderson right now boy
down below freezing in the 20s in the
front valley with some snow out in
pahrump as well beautiful there with the
low 30s at indian springs 20s in cali
any snow up in lincoln county 2 and 25
up in cedar city brian had by the way
picked up a foot of snow
so that's good for the ski resort up
there and mammoth over in california
picked up over four feet of snow with
this storm so here the valley rain
totals did really good up to a tenth to
two tenths of an inch of rain in areas
even over a quarter of an inch and a
third or more of an inch up in the
northwest out to far northwest summerlin
centennial hills you were close that's
thule springs up there at .39 so the
system now is gone it's already into the
rockies unfortunately it's going to head
towards the midwest and it's drawing up
already some very warm moist air out of
the gulf it's the exact scenario that
happened last friday night with those
deadly tornadoes in the mid-south
we are looking at another storm system
already moving into the pacific
northwest with rain and snow northern
nevada will get a taste of that northern
california will also get a taste of it
of course it was flooding rains over
southern california fortunately we
didn't have any flooding problems but
just enough of a drink of water from
mother nature that you might just want
to turn your sprinklers off today and
save a little water and if you are
running your sprinklers just make sure
it's during the daytime not at night
because we're going to get freezing
morning lows for the rest of the week
it's going to be cold 51 today a few
clouds here or there but a lot more
sunshine 35 the overnight low into early
tomorrow morning and a lot of nights
we're going to be right around that
freezing mark as we head into our last
weekend of fall
mostly sunny on monday but maybe a
slight chance of showers as we start off
winter on tuesday which officially
arrives tuesday morning